with me spirit of the Living God come
now and grow our faith deepen our hope
and strengthen our love and inspire
within each one of us the desire to be
your faithful friends forever in the
name of Jesus Christ amen some of you
know that next month I will go before
the presbytery of southern New England
for the very last assessment in this
process of ordination in the
Presbyterian Church USA and so in these
weeks proceeding as I'm preparing for
that I've taken up a practice that I've
borrowed from a friend of writing
letters and note cards to all of the
people who have helped kind of shape me
and guide me and bring me this far
it's an incredibly nostalgic kind of
process for me as try to set aside time
each day to pray for one person or one
community and to write to them and as
world communion sunday was approaching
it got me thinking I know it sounds
old-fashioned but just imagine with me
if each one of us was to write to all of
the people all of the Christian
communities all of the families that
have shaped us in faithfulness and
discipleship and brought us to this
place imagine just how far out that
would go I mean if each note card was
like a little paper airplane soaring out
from Vitello Chapel can you picture the
map with the little dotted lines and all
of the places that they would stop isn't
it amazing to think about the diversity
that's here in this room and the
connections that we have all over the
world to other Christians who are also
worshipping breaking bread baptized into
one body in the early church it was a
common practice to write lots of letters
in between the churches not just
of gratitude and Thanksgiving though
that was certainly a part of it but also
as a way of encouragement and you know
exhortation and so they would send these
letters Paul specifically sent lots of
letters we have some of them and and one
of the themes that is common throughout
all of them is a plea for unity Paul's
letter to the Romans is like these
others but it's also unique because Paul
didn't know that Church himself he'd
never been there before he didn't know
the people personally the way that he
did in Corinth and Ephesus and some of
the others and so his letter is less
personal and instead he lays out this
entire theological argument I mean it is
like it you know his treatise on what he
thinks about what God is up to in the
world and if you've ever read the letter
of Romans from beginning to end if you
haven't you should it it's amazing the
way that he turns the categories of
insider and outsider on its head over
and over and over again every time you
think that you're inside you realize it
or not and when you think that you are
outside then you find out oh no all of a
sudden you are welcome it's amazing it's
worth reading but one of the things that
he focuses his argument around is he
brings up the question of the covenant
with Abraham and who counts as Abraham's
progeny Abraham's descendants who are
the people who get to inherit all of the
blessings that God promised to Abraham
so long ago and he uses this this way of
thinking about who qualifies for the
inheritance and he comes up with a
really fascinating argument that got you
know that that raised them some good
conversation probably in the early
church but he basically focuses in on
Abraham's fatherhood and he argues that
it's actually not about genealogy it's
not about who your parents are and where
you were born and it's not actually
about Abraham's obedience to the divine
command
even though Abraham was obedient and is
a wonderful model of faithfulness it's
not about obedience to the law Abraham
saw
hood is defined by his trust in God's
power to accomplish God's Word of
promise even though all of the
circumstances seem to suggest that it is
not possible this is something that we
talked a little about a little bit about
at evening prayer this past weekend so
that was part of what got me thinking
Yana offered the the reflection and she
talked about how for Abraham and Sarah
at the moment of the call to go from
your family from your kindred your
father's house from your homeland to go
with the promise that you will be
blessed with many children I will make
of you a great nation and the world will
be blessed through you then at that time
Abraham was 75 years old and his wife
Sarah had been barren for years and yet
he trusted he believed and this is
something that Paul grabs a hold of and
says yes that is what makes Abraham a
father to us all yes indeed the Covenant
is true for those who are born who were
born to Abraham as his children
year after year generation after
generation all of his progeny are
inheritors of the promise yes also all
of those who are obedient to the law are
inheritors of the promise just like
Abraham and in Abraham but also also
those who trust in God's power to create
life where life did not exist before all
of those who trust in God's promise and
ability to raise life even from the dead
and so for all of these new people who
are trusting in the resurrection of
Jesus and the promise that that means
for God's kingdom here on earth they too
are Abraham's children they too are part
of this covenant and the promise and the
blessing this is obviously terribly
oversimplified the Hall has an
incredibly nuanced and beautiful
argument that stretches out over
chapters and chapters and uses all kinds
of scriptural allusions and quotations
and in reinterpretations but throughout
it all he's laying out this kind of
brazen argument that challenge is what
people really held true about their own
religion their own tradition and what in
their understanding of how God worked in
the world but as he's doing it he's
making this argument in order to exhort
the Romans over and over again welcome
one another as Christ has welcomed you
do not fall victim to the voices of
dissension and then at the end of the
letter he adds this final list of
greetings and it's common in most of his
letters he sends greetings but this one
is totally different in terms of its
length and detail as you heard the list
includes both women and men Gentiles and
Jews you can imagine that the list
includes all of the diversity of the
membership that he wants the Roman
Church to embody itself and so even as
he sends his own greetings to all of
these different people he's inviting his
readers to see them and to see this
community through his eyes and to value
them according to the things that he
values and so all of a sudden against
all of the kind of social categories
that we would typically use to sort
ourselves out right men and women so
gender and ethnicity and wealth and
maybe political leanings all of the
different things that we typically use
like the freshman Bazaar right all the
tables that are lined up are you
Republican you can be in this group are
you Christian you can be in this group
are you you know women in science you
can join over here all of the different
categories that we use to sort ourselves
out here Paul is instead presenting a
very different kind of belonging and
know even more primary identity and
listen to what he says as he describes
the reasons for welcoming each of these
people the reasons themselves actually
illustrate what he's talking about in
terms of trusting in God's Word he says
these people were generous
not only to me but tell a lot of other
people and they helped me they stood by
me even when it got them into trouble
they were imprisoned with me these
people risked their lives for me these
other folks are my family and these
might as well be I mean this woman she's
like a mother to me and he says greet
them greet them because they have been
like Christ to me greet them and welcome
them and embrace them because God has I
think for me on world communion sunday
it's difficult to fathom the unity of
the christian church around the world
especially I think given some of the
challenges that we face in the church
today but if each one of us were to list
all those people that we were writing to
before into this one big list and to
turn around and say greet these people
because they're my family and greet
these other ones because they helped me
out when I was in a tough spot and greet
these other ones because they've been
working really hard in the church and
they have been bringing about the first
fruits of God's kingdom greet all of
them because they have been a part of my
formation and my development as a
disciple greet them and welcome them and
embrace them because God has what a list
we would have and that gives me great
hope for the unity of the church when we
come forward and we break bread we
proclaim that it is one body that we are
one body the church and I think that
we proclaim it against even evidence
that would seem that it's not possible
we proclaim it because we are a
community that has a deep and abiding
trust in God's power to fulfill God's
promise in the world and we know that we
are just a small sliver of it but thanks
be to God for the diversity that we have